hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca I'm for honor again and
today we're gonna be doing a little bit
of a weird video this time something
different and we're gonna I'm gonna be
showing you every character and for
honor and their most spammed or most use
move in their move set for example a
rotating lights Pam's you go keys light
into headbutt and other things like that
there's gonna be roughly one the three
moves per character so I'm gonna be
showing a little bit of them just a few
of them but it's gonna be all the
characters there's going to be
timestamps in the description if you
want to go to your specific character
your main I totally understand that and
I don't want you to sit the whole thing
so if you don't want to so definitely
just check the description for your
specific character or the care if they
do you want they want to see and also
remember this video is an opinionated
video so yes this is going to be my
opinion a lot of people parently hate
that on the internet but this is going
to be my opinion so I'm sorry I happen
to disagree with your opinion but like I
said this is just mine and it's my video
they have without further ado I'm gonna
shut up and we can get into the video
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Tori Tori
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but yeah guys that's going to be the end
of the day hopefully guys didn't enjoy
like I said it's an opinionated video
it's my opinion so I do I do apologize
if you happen to disagree with any of
the moves that I showed but I hope you
found this video slightly entertaining
it did please feel evil like really just
help me out
subscribe it for a new I covered the
informational side aisle for honor that
being balance changes hero updates patch
note to leaks all that good [ __ ] those
doing some gladiator game playing mean
videos and some stupid [ __ ] like this so
a lot of four on our content as well so
just be on the lookout for that and my
two most recent videos will be on screen
if you guys do want to check that out
and with the guys hope every wrister day
thinking for watching the video and
peace out
[Music]